good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy wednesday
it's hump day which is so appropriate
because
there are you know few people in this
world i'd like to hunt more than i'd
like to hump today's co-host as you guys
probably know if you follow us on
instagram jackie is very sick she made
it work yesterday she cannot make it
work today she has 101 fever so i have
swapped one redhead for another redhead
because we are a network that believes
in redheads i love that about you guys
and i'm so happy you're here shannon
like i'm devastated my sister is sick
obviously but like i'm upset too i'm
obsessed
hi hi and the timing is perfect because
we were talking about you yesterday on
the podcast well for those who don't
know shannon like are you okay um
shannon is the best shannon is reality
star influencer queen podcaster and as
of yesterday her podcast probably a
podcast joined our toast news network
which we're so excited about no freaking
out freaking out thus making us the lead
the industry's leading podcast network
for redheads yeah which i feel like
people should talk about more i think
they should talk about i think you know
what else people should talk about more
is the fact that you are a natural
redhead oh yeah i am i well you know
what i'm so ferociously passionate about
my spray tans that i think that throws
people off the scent right and and so
they're always like you're not like
that's not your natural color they're
right i'm like i've never dyed my hair
ever that's so true because you know i
would have assumed like maybe even
before i met you like is she a real red
head i would have said no yeah um what
is your natural skin tone like what's
the color of your butt cheek like
um
i bet my armpit looks like that tan
always comes off oh my god
you're super like um porcelain yeah no
it's like pale pale pale oh that's so
interesting you're never like but you're
never oh wow but my dad is like a
quarter native american and like it
looks like a mahogany dresser right and
so tan you're not um you didn't get any
of that gorgeous i just don't i didn't
get the tan i tan a little bit easier
than most red hats although i try to
stay out of the sun because like skin
cancer but i don't freckle as much as
most redheads you have a [ __ ] ton of
freckles like i don't hate to break it
too i do but like you know some redheads
are they're bigger they're bigger you
have tiny little cute little frail ones
cute little freckles yeah um
i'm just making all this up i'm so
honored that you could join me i know
you're so busy because it's fashion week
and you're literally like the most
fashionable girl i know i mean look at
my outfit today i usually show up in
dirty underwear and leggings um but i
really pulled out all the stops for you
because the last time you were here i
wore leggings and a hoodie and you wore
like your prom dress and it wasn't right
i did do that and i should have told you
um you should have i should have told
you i i was just telling claudia i was
like i don't think i'm like
participating in fashion week as much as
i'm just like in new york during fashion
week which is also like fun and fun but
yeah um i just like wearing pretty
clothes i just really do and you wear
them so well like if i
wore the clothes like you wore them like
i would wear stunning things too you
know oh well if i could be so bold i
might unbutton this in a second take
your time this is a totally free space
save space save space that we're in the
trust tree they're just they're so tight
yeah so eventually i think i might just
so the last time you were here things
were different because now you have a
man
oh yeah yeah and i just want to know
like what it what's it like like he's an
international man so like you really
can't spend like every day with him
which has its benefits but also
obviously yeah it's you know what i
think i do long distance well i've never
done it before but like i'm it's not
that that bothers me as much because
he's so busy i'm so busy um he lives in
london but it's it's the [ __ ] time
difference yeah that bugs me like so
much happens so like let's he goes to
sleep at like 10 30 11 right and like
that is around three o'clock here oh so
you're done for the day at three o'clock
well it's just like so much happens from
the hours of like four
to ten for me like all the best like i'm
i'm having a glass of wine i'm unwinding
i'm relaxing like i'm in a better mood
like my work's done like yeah so much
happens and he's just like asleep oh you
know what that [ __ ] sucks yeah and so
that is like my only qualm
the time difference that's a pretty big
one i'm not gonna lie i mean it makes me
sad the timing difference makes me sad
sometimes i shouldn't like text him and
he's like you know in rem sleep no all
right right he's hit the rem cycle yeah
um but he's coming here right to visit
you for the first time yes so i've gone
to uh london twice uh i went on a family
vacation with his family so it's like
legit
like are you do you have a label like
he's your boyfriend yeah he's like okay
yeah he asked me to be his boy his
boyfriend he has to be his boyfriend
his girlfriend uh the second time i went
to london yeah after i met his parents
and stuff but uh yeah so i've gone to
europe three times this year and then
he's coming here um in like a week and a
half he's gonna we're gonna do new york
and then i split time in nashville so
we'll do a little bit in nashville and
then we're i'm taking him to the deep
south maybe he's gonna meet your parents
he's gonna meet my parents in south
carolina yeah so we're gonna do like a
little bit in charleston a little bit um
in lake murray where i'm from in south
carolina so how many boyfriends have you
brought home to your parents i'm a
relationship girly pop yeah i just am um
i was in these streets for a while but
like i would never introduce my parents
someone who wasn't like my boyfriend
yeah like we've had the discussion
you're my boyfriend so
i guess every
like true boyfriend which i've had maybe
like five in my life have met my parents
that's nice yeah that's appropriate yeah
but i would never just like introduce
him to someone that i was like [ __ ]
no of course not especially like taking
the trip to south carolina
journey sick um so what do you have
planned for him in new york
so here's the thing in like i'm gonna
need maybe like new york toasters slash
claudia because i keep annoying her to
help me out with this because like i
don't i i think he thinks i'm more of a
new yorker than i am right like i'm i l
i moved here in january and i split time
not well like i'm always like doing a
million you're never here i feel like
i'm never [ __ ] here so like he's like
well i can't wait to see what we do and
i'm like
i can't wait to figure it the [ __ ] out
like i don't know during the day is what
i'm struggling with like dinners at
night or eating right right during the
day i don't want to be like
yeah like are you gonna go to empire
state building like no so like when i
went to london he was like so do you
like
want to see big ben and i was like no
yeah right right it's a clock so like i
we drove by it like he was like pointed
to buckingham palace i was like cool i
don't know that's cool i don't even take
a tour no no you're not going to see the
queen no no so i was just like well well
not anymore yeah but like when you went
rip um
so uh yeah i um
i'm not gonna like take him to that
stuff i'm not gonna take him on a
fairytale see the statue of liberty um
but i do think i want to take him on
like maybe do a picnic in central park
just sound cute cute shopping obviously
yeah like shopping would be fun little
lunches but maybe if there's like a
concert that's like a fun thing oh
taking them to uh a hockey game because
it's perfect they don't do uh ice hockey
right in europe so he'll i got i like
[ __ ] spend a mortgage on glass seats
oh good for you i always you know i'm
always doing the most trying to impress
people it's really a burden no uh hello
have we met like same same so uh me
getting uh front row seats to your show
literally shannon's like i'm gonna come
to the show like great just let me know
how many tickets you need that she sends
me a screenshot she bought first her
tickets loved it felt so important and
the other people you invited were like
why did she put you in the front row
yeah i mean the thing is like when
people at like who i'm like my friends
and family they're like can we get
tickets i'm like yeah the thing is i
never know where their seats are yeah
yeah they're it's like a venue thing
it's like venue con obviously so when
everyone saw shannon in the front row
and like literally like
my family's like in the 11th row they're
like this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
she paid for them i did um but okay so
yeah so we're doing that and that'll be
fun but i don't know if there's
something that you can think of randomly
or anyone listening can think of that
they're like yeah send ideas it's really
hard to plan things like aren't touristy
and like cliche well even in nashville
and i've lived in nashville for eight
years i'm like
ah what do we [ __ ] do again like
because once you live somewhere you get
in your routine you get in your habits
you're not like every day you know hunky
tonkin i have definitely taken his ass
honky tongue oh my god like the way i've
never been happier
than i am when i go honky talking it is
euphoric it's euphoric some of like the
happiest moments of my life are like at
legends and like dueling pianos everyone
is just boot scoot and boogie everyone
no one feels silly no everyone's just
like on the same page yeah and here's
the thing here's like my biggest issue
with james like like our relationship is
really really wonderful right now but
something that i could see just like
absolutely tearing it apart is his um
taste of music i knew you were gonna say
that he doesn't [ __ ] with country he
doesn't [ __ ] with country but what's
worse which i can deal with that right
like it's fine like i'm not everyone's a
country person but however not
everyone's a country bumpkin um i call
myself a country mouse but you are like
i
can't get behind someone that's obsessed
with house music uh i don't know it's
like a europe thing it's a europe thing
it's so it's the worst music you could
ever listen to in your whole life it's
like if it's like it's
like the fact that he doesn't think it's
the same thing over and over again and
the fact that there's no lyrics
you're speaking my language i just don't
get it and he keeps like really truly
being like oh babe
you'll see you listen to this and then
you'll it'll make you fall in love with
house music i'm like i'm like okay and
then i would sit and i'm like i'm honest
with him i'm like it's not good shinani
you are literally reading my mind that's
not good i there's a special place in
hell for people who like love music with
no lyrics it's just not a vibe and
you're right i guess that compared to
did like disliking country music like
you can teach someone to like country
music but it's definitely a european
thing it's bad when i went to ibiza i uh
what ibiza it sounded like
ibiza um when i went there i was like
bored at the clubs because like i i was
just like losing interest because i just
like don't want to like just you need to
latch onto a lyric yeah i just can't i
um not a vibe that's really tough yeah
that might be the end and i'm telling
you no it could it could be
if you're listening to this always so
supportive you probably will listen to
that sorry music sucks babe when you
like do a podcast or something like do
you send it to him like i was talking
about podcast minute 35. um well the
podcast i did i just launched yesterday
with the morning test um i that one was
like about my trip to portugal and like
my trips with him so he definitely
listened to that one but
like okay so when we first met there was
a lot like i said i was in these streets
so when we first met i remember he was
like i want to listen to your podcast i
was like did that no because it was like
a story about like this guy that i met
this like dutch guy i met in a bar in
new york city oh you were there that
night oh of course you heard stories
from the next morning
oh we went to acme right it was at acme
like who meets a guy at acme i don't
know that was that was a feat in itself
because it's a like black hole it's like
a dark dark place but
it's literally dark it's literally dark
like good luck finding the door um but
yeah i know this guy likes uh you know
stayed the night over at my apartment
and like wouldn't leave and it was like
really hilarious and it was like a funny
story to just talk about like this one
night stand and
uh james was like i've listened to your
podcast and i was i was actually on a
flight and so i didn't get it the text
message until i landed and i got it that
was like i'm listening to it was called
the bedless dutchman
leaf because he i i had a theory that he
might have been homeless homeless
because he was like living at your
apartment all morning not wanting to
leave and like most guys like don't even
spend the night i know and i was like
you know what i'm saying he's like no
your bed is so comfortable you read so
comfortable and like he literally
wouldn't leave the next day it was like
really uncomfortable
that's literally horrible but however i
i yeah he whenever i saw which one he
listened to i was like
oh no because like at that time the
podcasts that were out were just like a
lot of like you know single life
sexcapades and like you know very like
sex in the city vibes and now they're
just different because i don't know you
like my life is ever evolving you know
and so
yeah i was like oh you listened to that
one and he did he was like yeah might
not should have been the one i listened
to and i was like can i say you just
made me realize because i forgot about
that night with the bedless dutchman um
how grateful i am to james
because
obviously i'm happy for you whatever now
i stay
yes okay so like when we were when you
were like on your single girl [ __ ] like
i would never get in the way of that but
like i'm a married [ __ ] and like we
just we can only go so far together yeah
um so like when we got to acme after we
had been oh we got marva's birthday
party yep and it was so much fun there
was like no one really for you to like
you know meet or flirt without marcus
birthday party it's like i had your full
attention um and then we get to act me
where there's just like these young hot
guys and i'm like obviously shannon's a
young hot girl she has to go and prosper
but what about me you know what about my
feelings and that is something i should
have taken into account yeah and like i
didn't see you for the rest of the night
like because you were like doing things
that you should be doing but like it
still hurt no and now like you have to
behave just like i do and we can behave
together i mean it's so much fun the
last time we went out the most fun is
that we don't behave together and that
we just go
wild and crazy and we love it but like
what's great is i do just want to just
like scream sing lyrics to every song
until um acme physically removes us from
the building right so like when james
comes like i don't think he's gonna like
acme because they play songs that we
know all the words to and he's gonna be
like where are the beats bruv wear the
bait i'm forcing him yeah he told me
what a brava is he's like not a bra but
bravo what is abrupt like culturally um
like someone who's just like uh i'm
trying to explain like what we would
call it we what like it's someone that's
like yeah like in america they'd be like
sup bro like yeah dude like like like
like
like
smashing this girl yeah
boy got it okay yeah and like a brav a
bravo someone was like um yeah so sick
does he call it the telly
like the telephone telephone television
oh uh
i think i have heard him say that before
because while we are two
english-speaking countries there are
vast cultural differences when i have
him on my podcast i am going to make a
he he said he did not realize how many
things there were so like i'm not like a
like sorry if you guys are upset with me
for this but i'm not a love island girly
pop so i feel like that really um that
really opened and broadened america's
horizon to how many different words they
have like snogging and all that stuff
cracking yeah like all that [ __ ] right
like blimey like his friend actually
says blimey no i may like blimey i'm
like what i mean it literally sounds
like a [ __ ] like made up yeah but um
yeah i'll say he'll say stuff like in
passing i'll be like what does that mean
he's like oh um and sometimes he doesn't
know how to explain it because everyone
just knows what it means and sometimes
he'll use what he had uh oh this this
word bosh for us it means like boom like
mic drop and he's like bosh and so i
asked him to explain what it meant and
he used another english word to explain
what it meant that i didn't know oh well
that's helpful james james you have got
to like break this down better honestly
i just feel like if i were to like
immerse myself in british culture i'd be
immersing myself in moira rose culture
you know oh yeah but there's a stark
difference because the accent i use for
him him and his family laugh really hard
because they're like that's not what we
sound like because the accent i use i'm
like hey darling like how are you from
that's like the queen yeah and he's like
he's like no one talks like that that
isn't like the most posh like posh posh
posh like overly he's like obnoxiously
possibly they're like hey binky hey
darling like he's like we don't talk
like that and i'm like okay that's fair
well you want to hear the craziest thing
yeah i've never been to london oh you
have it no it's not like new york i
think i know so it's like a place i
really want to go when me and margo were
actually um and now i'm like gonna
invite you because it's gonna be way
more fun um me and margo were talking
about how you know luke holmes is doing
a world tour and he is doing a show in
london next year he is and i think that
we should go like have a girls week in
london we could podcast from london they
have podcast studios in london right oh
yeah teams can help us i think they're
like nicer than that no for sure um and
like i think we should go we should i'm
so so
so down okay
oh and then we'll make james go and
we'll make him a country music early ah
we're gonna make one we're gonna make
them one we're gonna make one um so
shannon is here to talk about her
boyfriend but she's also here to do the
show with me it's wednesday which means
of course we have the fast five stories
you know some mindless news about what's
going on in social media and the
celebrity world
and now i'm just like doing the show
like imagining like james watching like
what is what is james gonna think what
are you thinking baby i just wanna
button my pants he's like blimey
blimey shannon put your knickers on
yeah yeah they call them trousers oh
what do you call undies knickers right
oh knickers uh i've never heard them say
knickers yeah i think that's like an old
school thing yeah yeah that's like don't
get you nick is in a twist okay that's
like this in a twist every time i do
like an english accent like it turns
russian like
um and then we also have your toasters
and i feel like shannon probably gives
really good advice oh i actually do so
let's dive in to the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
visa do you ever dream of starting
something game changing then visa can
help make it happen whether it's
creating and selling your own customized
sneakers for cats transforming your dorm
room into a plushy pop shop or finally
going mainstream with your streaming
side hustle or i don't know maybe it's
starting like the world's most famous
podcast network for redheads maybe
that's the great idea that's it so
whatever you're bold enough to try visa
has the power to help bring your game
changing ideas to life
visa anyone can change the game today's
episode is also brought to you by
bowling branch bowling branch uses the
best 100 organ organic cotton threads on
earth for a superior softness and a
better night's sleep their sheets aren't
just buttery breathable and impossibly
soft but they get softer with every wash
so as you guys know this is a bowling
branch house jackie is a bowling branch
house we both have the signature hemmed
collection that comes in all different
sizes for beds different colors i have
them in white for a king sized bed you
will immediately feel the difference of
their iconic signature sheets they're a
hundred percent free from toxins which
means no pesticides no formaldehyde or
other harsh chemicals and their sheets
feed the dippes deepest mattress and
they are labeled with a top and bottom
tag which makes it really easy to change
your sheets
um i am like constantly waking up before
my bowling brand cheats with like my
sheets off like it's the most annoying
thing i'm just like a really kind of
chaotic sleeper
and building branch is there for me
because they they know i'm a thick girly
um and they give you a 30 night risk
free trial with free shipping and
returns on all orders you can get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code toast at bowlingbranch.com
that's
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch
dot com
promo code toast
okay i changed my sheets last night ugh
it's sweating it's just
like a hog yeah it's really rough like
just oh and you know what i decided to
do which um i posted this on my
instagram story like i can not really
disclose how often i change my duvet
because i'm not willing for the backlash
right right but um i decided that enough
was enough like it was time it was time
to wash my duvet cover and
that is something that i'm willing to
admit that i just really think i should
hire someone to do next time right so i
used to um like
wash my own sheets and it was really a
toss-up it could be once a month or once
a year like it was beyond sheets yeah
all of it like the whole thing not even
just a duvet the whole thing i washed my
sheets pretty often no oh but i spray
chain really often so that um and i'm a
sweaty when i was like in charge of my
own life um that's what i used to do and
then about three years ago i was like
you know what
housekeeper enough's enough yeah and now
i go once a week i can't i can't justify
having a housekeeper for my tiny little
apartment in new york but my house in
nashville i feel lucky enough that i can
like that's actually like a really fair
statement yeah
i've never been
come i heard your bed is really
comfortable from the bedless dutchman
the bed is very comfortable
oh i just realized i'm wearing cowboy
boots uh you're also wearing louboutins
like always one upping me on my show
like my shoes are from revolve i want to
kill you fun fact dolly parton has these
exact ones
tumbled out a bit and i stumbled to the
kitchen we really should go to like a
dolly show i would like please no
yesterday like we were texting a lot i
was like let me plan something fun for
me and shannon so or all friends i was
like looking online for country concerts
in new york but like there really aren't
any
i think this week no not this week
that's what i was looking for i know
except this week i'm kind of busy
because i'm going to portland and
seattle this weekend tickets available
at girl no job.com tour my one and only
leg in the pacific northwest i can't
wait to see you there
all right first story of the day is that
leonardo dicaprio and gigi hadid are
dating they're moving to the next level
but still taking it slow according to
page six
so gigi and leo have moved their romance
into a more intimate phase but sources
close to the paris say they are quote
taking it slow sources have been telling
us for months that the model 27 and the
superstar actor 47 have been getting
close while hanging in the same group of
friends but now we hear that they've
started going out on dates just as a
twosome they've quote mostly been
hanging out in groups and a solo of
handful
of a solo
and solo a handful of times
the source says that dicaprio is not
someone who is in in and out of
relationships he doesn't jump around
hooking up but they are taking it slow
so these were like rumored ever everyone
heard it on jumaaw and now it's like
pretty much confirmed like i think last
night they both went to the same fashion
week event not together but they were
both photographed leaving and coming in
i just like i was just telling you i'm
still finding myself laughing i get over
stuff really quick like i'm like enough
like i remember the will smith slap i
think we talked yeah we did talk about
it and i was just like i'm not laughing
at it anymore it's the jokes are done
right i'm over it
i every single time i see a new joke
surface a new meme service about him
only getting 25 like people under 25
like they still make me giggle so this
is good that she's 27. by the way i
completely agree like when the internet
becomes obsessed with one thing it gets
like annoying and it's not funny anymore
and it's like fatigued
um this i find so crazy i don't know why
i thought
hadid was so much older than 27 perhaps
it's because she has a kid oh yeah and
she's accomplished a lot and we've known
her for like she got famous on
housewives when she was like 18. true so
you would think she was older yeah yeah
but i actually i actually always think
that the cardiac the jenners are younger
or younger yeah no they're in their 40s
no no no no oh kylie
and kendall yeah kendall is what like 26
but to be fair i think the kardashians i
always think the kardashians are going
to i always forget kim's almost 40 or is
40. he's 40 courtney is in her 30 in her
40s and i think chloe's about to turn
yeah it's i don't know i always they
don't you're right the hadith seem like
older and like there's a weird thing
with celebrities like when you find out
that two celebrities are the same age
like i think i read somewhere once that
like adele and taylor swift are the same
age no which just is really shocking and
i think that cardi b is also the same
age as them as well i saw that taylor
swift and cardi b the same age and i was
like laughing let me just cause that is
just a funny one because your brain
immediately compares the two people not
their ages and you're like how could
that be yeah adele is 34.
adele is 34 and taylor swift is 32
and cardi b is
29. cardi b's young
well cardi b's younger than taylor swift
and adele that maybe is what's funny
yeah no it's just like i guess with
celebrities maybe you remember them like
as like the person they were when they
were like peak fame i don't know what it
is maybe yeah yeah yeah but it's just
weird it is weird i'm happy that
obviously um
leo's dating someone who's over 25 but
she's 27 so it's like really never that
big of a difference but you were saying
she's a mom so that's like a shift
that's
like an upgrade for him yeah
i kind of feel like i know leonardo
dicaprio is obviously like the biggest
superstar movie handsome whatever but i
kind of feel like
he's like kind of kind of like run down
like i think he looks real hard and hung
up what yeah i i just i'm not like of
course he's still good looking and of
course he was a heart [ __ ]
throat but like i'm just like not i
think that the allure is there because
he's [ __ ] leonardo's decrepio
obviously but like i know and it used to
be that like he was dating these like
not famous girls who were so beautiful
but it like made sense because he was
like kind of dating beneath his a-list
star but they were so much younger so it
was it leveled out like right well
they're more attractive because they're
younger and now it's like i don't really
feel like that's going to be able to
apply much longer because he's like
like not to be so mean but like he's
getting ugly
he's not but you know who's also like
just straight up aging which we should
not talk like so no but you know what
this is how people talk about women ages
so you know what yeah leo's getting ugly
leo is getting uglier and here's the
thing i also think brad pitt is but like
oh i don't one would be like you don't
you look so greasy and his hair's
getting wispy maybe it's because like i
have like actual love in my heart for
him like you know when you love someone
you think they're beautiful always yeah
like you love your child but like you
don't realize like your baby's ugly you
know i'm totally kidding i mean that's
the thing for sure i i
really i feel that way about um matthew
mcconaughey
is aging well yeah no by the way that's
just like straight facts but that's just
like a country man it's so true and so
country men have grit and that's why
they look sexy longer and older that's
so true brad pitt you're just giving
greasy hollywood old to me and i don't
like it yeah i mean i guess like you
know if i took out like from a total
unbiased third party perspective like
brad pitt like is looking worse for the
wear yeah um
but i still think he's like extremely
handsome he is
like and so cute but not leo no i'm just
like i'm getting over him
yeah leo sometimes looks like he has
jaundice i just feel like it hasn't been
the same between me and leo ever since
he saw me in a bathing suit you know
what i mean i took a boat trip with leo
once where in mexico i can't tell if
you're being i'm being dead serious you
obviously didn't read my book because it
was in there damn it um yeah yeah and
honestly it just like it changed things
between us yeah and then like we jumped
off the boat
and they were like let's swim to the
beach and like you know depth perception
is off when you're on a boat like you
think the coast is like the beach is
right there yeah um but it wasn't and so
like we were all kind of like dying um
but like me specifically because like
leo and like everyone there was like
really in shape um swimming's hard no it
was horrible it's the only exercise that
works every muscle in your body and one
of the like staff members from the boat
like got on a paddle board and came and
picked me up don't tell me anymore i
want to read the book came and picked me
up and left me on the beach like and i
literally was parked there like a
beached whale and like once we got to
the beach i was like great can we go
back but you guys want to like hike
around i'm like what no
so i just pretty much sat there while
everyone like hiked and that's really
kind of where like my relationships like
ended with him that what's about like
the worst part about me is i am such a
follower sometimes that like i would
have been like yeah
you know just been like like i would
have looked dumber no by the way so
would i for anything like except for
hiking like if he had said like let's do
ashwagandha i would have been like
okay i mean i'll probably die but like
leo said so so yeah i'm a follower loser
too but like my body is limited in some
ways i would have just looked haggard
walking up the hill and like
you know we were like getting out of the
ocean like sopping wet like i looked
like a raisin like it was just not i've
been there where i thought the the swim
was closer than it was and it's just it
never is it never is it never is and the
thing about me is like i actually love
to swim like i'm i'm kind of like a i'm
not a water sign but like i'm i'm a
swimmer i like to frolic in the water a
lot i grew up on a lake so i just like
really enjoy being in the water but i
just like existing in the water and my
sister was always the [ __ ] that was
like tanning no she'd be like let's race
to the buoy and i was like no i just
want to like jump off the boat and swim
yeah no i might want to like i might
have been like a race to the booby girl
too
um but like when you go on vacation like
are you the girl who like doesn't like
get her hair wet no no no um everyone
would assume that about me and everyone
is always shocked that i'm like the
first one to jump in the first one to
like get underwater i just yeah can we
go on vacation together yes okay because
like i was gonna ask you if i could come
to church and get cause when you guys
were oh oh my god i wish you had asked i
was gonna be like if i got a flight is
there like room for me to sleep yes oh
my god i wish you had asked i could kill
you to myself you just can't ask people
that kind of why not well literally why
not but i just saw that you guys are
just like jumping in the water that's
just how i like to enjoy vacation and i
actually almost all my friends um
obviously if i go on like a revolve trip
usually the girly pops aren't like
popping in the water immediately but
like for me personally i i took a
picture and then i got the [ __ ] in the
water yeah no i'm the thing about me
like i'm going to get in the water
i love just want to jump off stuff i
want to me too
i'm planning a trip okay like asap i'll
come to portland do they have water
there um i don't know
and i don't want to wait star trek on
point um portland portland i can't talk
today like i want to go to like the
caribbean with you okay
okay um next up is some britney spears
controversy because apparently she was
on instagram every day yesterday calling
everybody fat britney spears responded
to backlash after seemingly body shaming
christina aguilera and her backup
dancers
basically she posted an instagram like
graphic that said you know i've always
you know the best way to look skinny is
by standing next to someone fat
and then in the um
caption she was like yeah like if i ever
stood next to christina aguilera's
backup dancers i would have looked like
it was so weird and then she issued an
apology she said by no means was i being
critical of christina's beautiful body
it is what it is this is what it is yeah
no it's like not an apology i flew to
see your show once and the main thing i
noticed was the difference of our people
on stage
by no means did i even mention christina
look at my post i was inspired by her
show and she's a beautiful woman of
power thank you at xtina for inspiring
me she went on to clarify that she
didn't mean to be critical of anybody
rather she saw her original post as a
projection of the insecurities i deal
with all the time as a result of how my
parents and the media have treated me
um
and i just want to say like this is
something i noticed when brittany was
free and then she was very active on
social media she posted um some jeffree
star cosmetics and people were
commenting so she deleted it and
apologized for supporting jeffree star
and i just really need people to stop
expecting britney spears to like be like
completely caught up on all things woke
and political correctness because like
are you seeing what's going on like
she's free but she's not like a hundred
percent well yeah mind is still in a
cage right who knows what she was
allowed to access i mean i i didn't do
as as deep of a deep dive on the free
britney stuff as some people did so you
might know who knows what she was able
to look at like we have been growing
with the times evolving right because we
have a phone in front of our face with
news right people saying what you
shouldn't shouldn't say anymore we're
growing and learning as a society right
who knows if she was able to do that she
was on [ __ ] lithium like leave her
alone like her brain is definitely not
fully bounced back to like what it was
before she was put on drugs and like the
way that like we're now canceling
brittany like don't get me wrong what
she said like that was not great if
anyone else said it i'd be saying
something different but like can we stop
having like normal expectations for
brittany because she's not this isn't a
normal situation i just you said it
before too you were like you can't
expect someone that's just not well too
well that that in itself is us being
highly critical of someone that like we
can't it's not the same situation as us
no it's so
people are like this whole like call out
culture like they've gotten a little
ahead of themselves like britney spears
is not fair game yet i agree i agree i
let her live when you were reading that
i was like appalled but like you said
i'm like but it's it's britney spears
like she's she gets a pass she's not
well she's not well and i'm sorry she
gets a pass yes like i'm not you're not
gonna find me caring like normally when
people are saying fat phobic things like
yeah i'm out here being like a
a spokesperson for my people this time
i'm not coming for brittany like she's
been through enough like she doesn't
need to get dragged on twitter now okay
yeah like let the woman live
speaking of women who are just living
jennifer lawrence is breaking down this
season of real housewives of beverly
hills including quote evil eric james i
[ __ ] love this so we all know
jennifer lawrence is a famous housewives
franchise superfan and the actor has
proclaimed proclaimed her love for the
bravo series several times and even
appeared on watch weapons live with
danny cohen well she was at the toronto
international film festival for her film
causeway she was chatting with variety
about her take on the this most recent
season of the real house size of beverly
hills and particularly the housewife
erica jane as we all know jane has been
the center of several controversies
including um her husband tom gerardi
allegedly embezzling millions of dollars
from victims of horrific accidents yadda
yadda we all know so here's what jayla's
take on the season is
my biggest problem with this season
is that it's just been boring and i
think that erica is evil
i would go as far as to say she needs a
publicist asap
um she also suggested that erica jane's
fellow cast members had a duty to help
the chicago star realize how badly she
is coming across it was like comparing
the situation to the famous episode of
house as of new york in which the cast
allowed tipsy during the medley to film
for hours with lipstick smeared across
her face that's actually a really good
comparison i didn't remember that um i
do feel like the women of beverly hills
are like doing their best to protect
erica but she's just so [ __ ] crazy
and radioactive like there's only so
much you can help someone that is true
and i like was just thinking to myself
if if any celebrity massive superstar
like
said something horrible about me i would
just be devastated but like let alone
one that's just like so lovable and like
real and real and hilarious like when
she comes for you like jayla like she
like is so intelligent with her humor
much like jackie
like
it almost cuts deeper because it's mean
and funny and you're like [ __ ] and like
if she called me evil i would just be
die so upset no and the thing is with
being a bravo liberty the cool thing is
that there are so many mainstream a-list
celebrities chrissy teigen rihanna so
cool are vocal about their love of the
shows they'll even call people out
sometimes yeah but they'll never call
out negatively they'll always be like i
love tom schwartz that's what rhianna
posted right and even if rihanna was
like hating ariana maddox she never says
it because it's like what's the point
it's like mean it's like she's like i'm
too famous for that it's an imbalance of
power yes but this is like the first
time that a celebrity like a
mega a-lister has like said something
negative about a franchise and about a
cast mate i just remembered because you
just said that when rihanna was like
obsessed with that trumpet whatever that
scene of tom tom brushing his teeth i
thought it was it was brushing he was
doing something it was like a mash-up
and she was like whoever the editors are
of this show like i literally want to
kiss you on my mouth this is the
funniest [ __ ] ever and i was like that
must have been so cool for tom schwartz
so cool and so like there are a few
moments like that but there's never been
a moment like this where you're getting
dragged you know erica jane though just
like i don't know about that who are you
jayla i was you you were in diapers
whenever i was doing she's gonna like
name something she was doing like i
don't know blowing someone famous
when
while
law was still in diapers that's so true
because she's like kind of off the deep
end now like i don't think she can be
saved no which is so sad i did not not
expect erica jane to go from being like
one of my favorite and just like
that
franchise favorite you
yeah she's like talented she was
beautiful she was in vogue like she had
so much going for her and obviously a
scandal can take you down but i think
she could have recovered if she handled
it like even one iota better than she
handled it i would go as far as to say
she needs a publicist asap asap she
needs a publicist jennifer lawrence was
being so funny because she was looking
for the right word she's like and i just
think eric is like and really the only
word to describe how she's acting is
like evil yeah because she's been so
heartless to her castmates to the
victims of her husband yes that's really
the perfect word and when she said it i
was like yeah
pop off queen pop off queen i agree
i have two more stories for you shin on
okay i mean might i just say you're
absolutely killing it um and the two
remaining stories are brought to you by
figgs everyone is something that they
look forward to in the fall and if
you're in healthcare there's something
extra exciting on the horizon and that's
the brand new colors and styles from
figs if you haven't heard figs makes the
comfiest scrubs around they're
engineered with the innovative technical
comfort technology to be ridiculously
soft and incredibly durable so you're
always ready to take on the day in style
obviously i do not work in healthcare
but i appreciate a comfortable set of
clothing and i do own many pairs of figs
because they're extremely breathable
extremely soft and come in stunning
design
so they're 100 awesome scrubs that are
focused on design function and comfort
they have a soft proprietary four-way
stretch the fabric is moisture wicking
anti-wrinkle and anti-odor they have up
to 20 pockets on some of their styles
and they easily customize yours with
text and icon embroidery and if you
don't know where to start check out
their new fall colors for a look that's
100 awesome all season long their super
popular core scrubs never go out of
style and they are an easy way to mix
and match figgs believes that the
awesome humans in healthcare deserve
awesome scrubs to match head to
wherefigs.com use code toast to get 15
off your first order that's
w-e-a-r-f-i-g-s
dot com promo code toast
all right
um some like kind of crazy emotional
amazing news
ryan lettled
i'm literally having a stroke today
ryan reynolds undergoes a life-saving
colonoscopy and it was all caught on
video aren't all colonoscopies videoed
such a good point um and they sticking a
camera in your colon and i'm super super
happy that it was like a positive test
but like
i just feel like this is one of those
situations where like celebrities are
getting too comfortable with like ryan
reynolds is like universally beloved not
by me but but by most people
yeah um yeah i find him like annoying
and i feel like he's like a monster to
be married to um but like for the most
part everyone loves him like every time
he like farts e news he's like oh my god
you have to check out this fart it's
amazing
um
so now he's getting like a little too
comfortable with that level of praise
because i i just don't really feel like
we need to know about like your
colonoscopy and like the video it's like
a lot something that's gonna be private
a video that he shared of like the video
of this colon or was it him laying down
getting a colonoscopy so he had a subtle
polyp on his colon during his first
colonoscopy which he was broadcasting in
order to destigmatize the procedure that
i understand cool the deadpool actor and
his wrexham soccer club co-chairman oh
my god rob okay i didn't read the story
so like now i feel like i was being mean
okay sorry i'm taking everything back
so the deadpool actor and his co-star
rob
mcclellany decided to partner up with
lead from behind a colon cancer oh my
god i feel like such a [ __ ]
like in my defense jackie picks the
stories and right before we started i
realized like i was supposed to pick the
story today so i picked them without
reading and that was not cool um and i
take back everything i said like now i'm
dying i do still find ryan reynolds
annoying but this is nice he partnered
up with lead from behind a colon cancer
awareness organization to encourage
people especially men to get the
procedure when the time comes in a
youtube video uploaded to reynolds page
on tuesday him and his co-star explained
that they wanted to prove how the simple
step can save lives he said i would
never normally have any medical
procedure put on a camera and then
shared okay i'm like such a [ __ ] i'm so
sorry listen um this is really nice this
is nice and look at me like i'm out here
continuing the stigma
that they are trying to destigmatize i'm
the problem
i'm sorry i take it back i didn't mean
to offend that's really nice that is
yeah it's it's good i was curious though
i mean if you just read the headline
this is the problem with clickbait
sometimes it's just
confusing and not everyone's gonna read
the whole story what ryan reynolds said
was that it's not every day that you can
raise awareness about something that
will definitely save lives that's
something motivation for me to let you
in on a camera that's being shoved up my
ass
um so i'm
like a [ __ ] and i'm really sorry do you
remember when the uh not
not a
housewives franchise but desperate
housewives the the television show oh my
god you don't even have to make the
discrepancy like i am a desperate
housewives historian
so am i who do you identify with as um
well it's easy to say bree with the red
hair that's what i was gonna say but i
don't identify with her yeah you're very
gabby i
i really was going to say gabby i just
like didn't want to seem like a [ __ ] no
no gabby evolves a lot in the show yes
like she gets severely humbled um no i i
would like to say that like i'm someone
that has body dysmorphia i think she's
hotter than she is and is humbled often
and they are that hot like that's a
thing
but i i just like i really i relate to
her i think uh susan is so [ __ ]
stupid
she's so stupid i could literally write
a 30-page dissertation on how i think
susan is a dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] she's so
dumb um and that's the thing with
certain shows um jackie and i talk about
this a lot is like you watch them and
then maybe you re-watch that when you
get older and i have recently re-watched
desperate housewives i did too i watched
it when it was coming on everywhere
with my mom she should not have let me
watch no by the way it was so
inappropriate but like we literally all
used to getting olivia's bed and watched
monday nights insane and then brothers
and sisters is on afterwards i didn't
watch that but one either watched uh
desperate housewives and like decided to
rewatch it a couple of years ago as an
adult and i was like oh my i really fell
in love with them
my mom watched re-watched it with me i
just loved it but brie then miss
vandecamp i'm pretty sure i could i
don't think i'm getting this wrong she
had cancer yes she had um anal cancer
yes and i'm like really respected marsha
cross is her name yeah marcia crusher
she came out and she said like
um what i'm not gonna like i'm gonna be
embarrassed that the cancer that i have
decided to choose my anus yeah no like i
forget the quote she used it was way
more dignified it was very like
rebounding yeah and it was like very
like to like i was like damn you're
right like i could i god hope i don't
but like if i have ass cancer i want
just as much sympathy for ass cancer no
she i remember that too um she was super
brave and open about it yeah 100 right
and like now i'm just like feeling worse
about what i said no it was clickbait
you don't know um also just back to
desperate housewives so i feel like when
we watch a show like susan was kind of
like the main character like yeah you
know that all four of them were like she
was really the star totally and she
[ __ ] sucked and like i liked her when
i was watching the show originally and
then i when i re-watched it i was like
oh my god she's literally the [ __ ]
worst that also i had the same
experience with carrie bradshaw like
she's the worst okay and i want to say
justice for lynette i think i'm a
lynette lynette oh my god and she just
like what a tortured soul what she's
someone she's had such a hard life i
know remember like at the end when like
tom like leaves her yes
that was tough i've chilled
literally i okay i will never forget i
was on a flight and like when i was
re-watching desperate housewives i was
talking about it on the toast and like a
lot of the toasters then started to
watch it along with me it's so good and
when i got to the part where tom um like
does i don't know if he has an affair
yeah he has an affair and then he moves
in with her yeah um and like leaves
lynette um somebody started a thread in
one of our facebook groups just like
talking about tom scavo and literally
like it was the funniest thing ever
because he was like the hottest husband
oh yeah he was because he was with the
kids yeah and like everyone loved him
but like as a husband he was a [ __ ]
remember like he opened that pizzeria
like he was always making bad business
decisions he wouldn't let lynette go
back to work like he was the [ __ ]
worst misogynist but then right after my
renaissance with desperate housewives i
had like the craziest sexiest stream
about carlos oh okay well i feel like
they were always giving dreams about
they were always like in the in the show
making dreams about carlos yeah and now
like that dream just kind of like
changed the way i saw carlos and like
now i'm obsessed with him i always i
always thought carlos was hot yeah
because there's something about like a
man that just like like goes to jail for
like [ __ ] someone up like i never
said that's kind of hot 100 and then um
why can i the whole time i've been
trying to think of her name what the
[ __ ] not not phoebe uh
and you know why we're always talking
about you're gonna love this do you know
why we're always talking about desperate
housewives on the toast why
um because there's an actor do you
remember the guy who played dave he had
like platinum white hair
piercing blue yeah yes so scary he was
like a random character and i think he
was like a killer yeah he also said he
married edie
in real life no no no oh yeah okay okay
yeah he is like an actor who um
refuses he will not kiss
another actress as a part of his job he
won't like do enemies intimacy scenes he
will not kiss an actor and like see
mormon i don't know what his reasons are
i think it's just because he loves his
wife
um
but like really [ __ ] stupid um and
we're always talking about him that's
interesting you know what though he
gives off the vibe that he would be like
no like he has all these like rules and
like lists and things like he freaks me
the [ __ ] out personally i don't like him
he i yeah i agree i don't like them the
show is perfection and did you ever
watch um so good
the guy who created it is named mark
cherry and he just
started another show
how women it's something about murder
can you look it up it was like olivia's
like women who kill something like that
mark cherry like women kill why women
can't kill it really is nothing like um
desperate housewives but it's incredibly
good the first season is so good the
second season was like fine the first
season was really good okay he's like
obvious he's just like a genius he has
like a magical touch yes we need to
bring back desperate housewives god i'll
i'll rewatch it like i know this is
making me want to re-watch it it is for
our fifth and final story we have some
parenting news from kourtney kardashian
because she reveals the response to her
son mason asking for mcdonald's french
fries after going a year without them
okay so she's obviously doing a lot of
press for lemmy she was doing the wall
street journal magazine interview so she
shared an example of a recent incident
that took place when she was enjoying
one-on-one time with mason
um and she's been so mindful recently
about clean eating so he said mom i need
mcdonald's french fries today please
it's been a year since i've had it
she was like today's not the day sorry
oh yikes
okay wait that's the end of the story
yeah that's literally what she's sharing
like setting boundaries and like i
totally believe in like you know having
your kids be clean eating and wanting
them to eat healthy i grew up in an
extremely healthy household and look at
me now so maybe i should have just been
able to eat mcdonald's fries when i want
to do oh my god i grew up like eating
the
crazy [ __ ] in south carolina like bad or
good bad see like god and look at us
both like you would think no seriously
like you would think shannon grew up in
the healthy house no no no i i look back
and like i i this is absolutely no shade
towards my mother at all but like i look
back and i'm like i cannot believe that
those were like we were just like
yolking cosmic brownies as like a
breakfast yeah no i was not like i was
having like full blown like scrambled
eggs that's so nice i'm sure my my
parents made great food all the time but
like i yeah i get where courtney is
coming from i actually had a friend
growing up in middle school and high
school who her parents did not let them
eat that kind of stuff so in high school
she found that kind of stuff gross and i
remember thinking like at first she was
weird but then being like that's kind of
nice because obviously that [ __ ] is
addicting like yeah but everything's
good in moderation like your kid who you
love is like please can i have these
french fries
he's not asking for meth i mean like i
really that's that's what i was gonna
make i'm just like i just don't see i
see if if you grew up not giving a ship
so then they grew up like my friend and
she just didn't want it sure sure but
for you begging but he was like can i
have him i haven't had him in a year and
his friends are like oh my god i had
nuggets last night they were so good he
just wants to fit in and i think you
know a little toxicity in moderation
isn't bad i just think your kid's gonna
go buck wild one day when he's 18. and
when he can drive or whatever and what's
so true your kids start hiding [ __ ]
mcdonald's french fries underneath the
bed don't worry they won't actually rot
because they're so much that's been so
true and by the way that's literally how
kids like develop eating disorders it is
because when they get to be 18 and
they're like allowed to like hoard and
binge it's so true not that i'm saying
that that's what's gonna happen and
obviously i'm not a parent and every
parent's decision is right but like my
god the kid is like please can i just
have a friend try french fries like of
all the things you can eat at mcdonald's
like french fries are not the worst no
no no and they're just they're just so
[ __ ] good no like i know we're going
to lunch after this and like we have
like fancy reservations like should we
just go to mcdonald's i would i would in
our gorgeous outfits should and vlog it
and vlog it oh you know what we make a
vlog after this because i texted chad
and yesterday like every time i see
shannon like i want a new purse what
person you're wearing today you have
fabulous style um thank you so much it's
this little findi girly pop like i said
i love her like i said
so we are going to go shopping and buy
matching purses wait and we should
definitely vlog it she sent me that and
i go i don't know if you're kidding
because like you know your sense of
humor is pretty elevated and sometimes i
like wow thank you i don't know if
you're like being funny or not but that
is something that i personally i'm an
adult woman who does still enjoy a
matching moment with one of my girls i
just really like it and so yeah and like
maybe we'll get like maybe a different
color or like if you find a bag that you
love and i find a bag that i love like
we'll buy separate bags but like from
the same store like yeah same brand
and my best friend taylor oh the sling
bag i had a different sleeping bag she
had a slim bag like i just like i really
like to do that yes
that's what we're gonna do today and i
feel really good about the decision okay
and also we're gonna get fries okay oh i
bought a disposable camera because i'm
such a millennial
you've been hanging out with the
snatcher too much oh my gosh she does
that too well everyone does it well
literally like she we in turks and
caicos she was like those pictures were
so [ __ ] cute they were so disgusting
like literally she sent us she finally
got them developed and it was just like
seven like [ __ ] ugly beasts i was
like marco you cannot post that
like i thought film was supposed to be
like really flattering
yeah it's not well mine's black and
white oh that's cool i think so too
we'll see okay we'll take some pics
there's a place in new york that you can
get them developed the same day yes did
margaret tell you about it no i text one
of my friends it's actually photographer
and i was like i bought this like thing
from she was like
yeah
um before we dive into our final segment
which is dear toaster shannon is going
to be helping me give you guys advice
from today you if you ever want to write
in it's dear toasters at gmail.com it is
brought to you by pear eyewear your
style is constantly evolving especially
if you're friends with shannon ford and
it's time that your glasses start
keeping up with pear eyewear changing up
your frames is easier than ever just
snap on a new design to transform your
look whenever the mood strikes one pair
endless possibilities but who says that
glasses have to be boring
so whether your vibe is retro classic
like if you wear glasses like it's kind
of annoying you have to wear the same
glasses every day but pear eyewear is
amazing because you get this you got a
pair of glasses then you get these
magnetic like um add-ons that just add a
different color add a different pattern
so if you're wearing like purple like
shine you could wear purple glasses if
you wanted an all-white coastal
grandmother look like me like you could
go for white um they have a huge range
of iconic basic shapes that started to
60 including your prescription so you
then choose from the hundreds of
matching magnetic tops that make it easy
to switch up your look and you can rock
the same design all day long change it
up every hour there's no wrong way to
pair get glasses as ever changing as you
are with pear go to pear eyewear dot com
slash toast for 15 off your first
purchase that's 15 off at p a i r
eyewear dot com toast i have those and
um they actually come with a really cool
case too where your glasses go in the
case and then they have this little like
flap that holds the little snap-ons oh
that is cool really nice you never lose
them look at you i know i like pear are
you ready to help save some lives yes
okay
first up hey guys love you well this was
going to jackie but i'm sure she would
say love you and okay love the show i
love you too um my husband and i dated
all through college and we got married
right after graduation we've been
married for over a year and it's been
going great until recently i haven't had
any sex drive or attractiveness towards
him everything he does just annoys the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of me and i just want
to be left alone when i'm around him
which is horrible because he's a total p
john and he does everything for me
recently when going out with friends
i've noticed men talking to me a lot and
i feel the urge to flirt and talk back
because it actually gets me excited
rather than when when i'm with my
husband i'm just annoyed with him it
leads me to wonder if i got married too
young and missed opportunities i know
this is 100 of me problem but how do i
fix it sincerely a confused toaster who
could never break someone's heart oh
well the thing is i was going to say
like you know a lot of things can be
going on in your life like or
health-wise or stress that like make
your libido go down yeah birth control
but if you're going out and like vibing
with others i don't think that's the
case i agree yeah that's what changed my
mind on the advice too um i do think you
owe it to this man to like try and make
it work whether that's like go to like
do a kakama suture class like when
you've been with someone for a long time
like it's easy to get into a rut and
then like you start seeing them more as
like a brother than a husband yeah um so
you have to make a conscious effort to
like keep it exciting you could
literally there are so many avenues you
could literally go see a sex therapist
you could say like i like if this guy
really is such a peach like then you can
say like i love you so much i want to
like make our lives a little bit more
exciting i thought maybe we could go see
a sex therapist no guy is going to hear
the word sex and not want more of it so
like it's like that scene in sex in the
city when charlotte and trey like can't
really you know oh yeah yeah and she
goes to that kamasutra woman who shows
you how to give the best fellatio of
your life yeah you're not fellatio is
fellatio [ __ ] yeah felicio and then
that's cuddling yes yes yes she yeah and
then miranda accidentally gets jizz in
her hair yes
um so you have to give it a shot before
you can't just like you know throw your
hands up because it's a marriage yeah
and listen i'm just like i just really
so deeply and passionately like i know
divorce happens but like i'm not married
yet and i just really really really
don't want to get divorced i know anyone
that gets divorced doesn't want to yes
but i say it's a really big step getting
divorced is like a big big big deal so
two things can exist but your parents
are still together right parents are
still together so that's like a very you
know like naive take it's like as a
child of divorce like yeah whatever
people get divorced life goes on totally
totally and i so but what i'm saying is
like two things can exist at one time
you could be really [ __ ] annoyed at
your husband but you still love them so
like that's so don't don't beat yourself
up too much for like just going through
something right now like maybe try to
dissect and like look inward a little
bit what's going on in your life what
are you taking any like medication yeah
all that kind of stuff like plays a part
don't just like give up so easy though i
think by the way that's like really good
advice like two things can be true at
once like you're not that's the thing
with marriage it's like not every minute
every night is gonna be whirlwind
romance multiple orgasms like yeah life
is hard and like that's what a marriage
is it's more of a partnership than like
a whirlwind like romance novels and
movies
don't prepare us for what marriage
really is one you just gotta like wake
up and decide to like fight for it to
try yeah to work for it so true so you
if that's not to say that this might not
be working out but you have to give it
like a really fair shot oh and the last
thing i'll say is it's not fair to him
if you don't tell him this stuff because
he has no idea so like he might be doing
he might like he might go take a cl uh
what's it called kamasutra or suture
class if he knew you were feeling this
way like it's almost a little unfair to
him that you're not letting on that
anything's wrong and so he's not doing
anything to fix it he might want to fix
it yeah like maybe he like is like
reading books behind your back like
maybe he's trying to help like help him
help you yeah
all right next up hello jack hello
shannon and claudia am i being insecure
no sorry she said am i being an insecure
wench i appreciate your candidate advice
and i need you to both weigh in
my boyfriend of three and a half years
started to masturbate and watch porn
literally every morning during work we
work from home
his office is upstairs and i've walked
in on him at least eight plus times at
first i felt awkward and said something
like do you need any help he just laughs
it off and says no when i first talked
to him about it he says it's due to his
stressful job that it's a way for him to
relieve stress throughout the day well
i'm a google girly so i took to the
internet and sure enough there's a ton
of research about how masturbation is a
good for stress relief i brought it up
again yesterday
sorry i brought it up again recently
because i'm starting to feel insecure we
definitely have not been having sex very
often as he seems very disinterested yet
he'll masturbate and watch porn is this
something every boyfriend does
i'm just if i'm just being insecure or
am i feeling validated no sorry
if i'm just being insecure or am i valid
and feeling compared to these women he's
watching online he does not have an
instagram i know he isn't on like on
only fans but i still feel hurt any
thoughts and insight would be so
appreciated a possible insecure wench no
you're doing nothing wrong like nothing
wrong i have such a take on this if he's
masturbating a lot like that's fine
because it is like a stress relief thing
but if that's taking away from
your sex then there's a problem and it
seems like he might
have a porn addiction problem and here's
what i think so i actually have such a
like you were just talking about this on
your instagram story yes okay so since
meeting james james i don't know like
what brought this up when we were we
just had like really deep conversations
really early on and he was i used to be
the girl so i i so feel for you at the
end of that where you're like am i just
being insecure like because i was the
girl that wanted to be so cool like like
oh no i would tell people like i don't
care if my boyfriend watches porn i'll
watch with him like no i wouldn't he
would be watching it behind my back and
closed doors like i was never doing that
with him that would be sexy we weren't
doing that right so he was like i just
always was like no no it's fine i'm not
insecure he can watch i don't care like
i did care obviously it's not weird to
care that your boyfriend is enjoying
watching other naked women have
intercourse like that is obviously not a
vibe it's like a boundary if you feel
that way some but there are some girls
who truly really don't care and that's
good for you that is also fine that's
something i really for a while there and
if i found out my boyfriend watched porn
i wouldn't like be like oh he's cheating
on me yeah some people who take it that
far and that's also their right to have
that opinion but
james has actually like plugged in for a
second he has a whole podcast where he
talks about um how your dopamine
receptors are so affected by porn and
here's the thing you went took to google
and you saw that masturbating as a
stress reliever and maybe sometimes he's
like i don't have time to like have sex
indeed you need to actually masturbate
but i would i would say that he should
close his eyes and and use his
imagination and masturbate because it is
a healthy thing to do i don't think he
should be watching other women or like i
don't know maybe you can be like fun and
sexy and be like it makes me a little
upset
that well no like it makes me a little
upset that you're watching other people
have sex to get off if you just need to
master it really quick like can we
record ours like oh yeah can you record
me giving you good advice can you record
us and can you watch us but the thing is
is that i don't think this guy he's just
i think he's reality no i think he's
also like somewhat addicted to them to
the porn more so than the masturbation
porn addiction is like totally a real
thing i fell into like a rabbit hole on
tick tock yes um a lot of people like
accidentally you know stumble on porn
when they're like 12 years old on the
internet and spend like 10 years
watching yes um and i feel like that's
what it kind of sounds like it's so
accessible it's so accessible and here's
the thing too like
you he really is watching so much porn
that his perception of real life sex is
probably why you aren't having as much
sex his perception of and i'm like
you're stealing all of this from james
podcast because literally that's such a
good point it just distorts his reality
and you're watching these like excuse my
french with these like perfect footsies
and by the way but sex isn't like that
because that's literally like perfect
lighting makeup everything no one's
actually coming like it's yeah it's
literally fraudulent yeah so i just
think like it's definitely something i
think you should bring up and to make
you feel better i dated someone um when
i first moved to nashville for a year
and a half that was absolutely addicted
to porn and he absolutely couldn't like
get it up whenever we were having sex
and he would apologize to me and say
like i'm sorry like i i like masturbated
earlier and watched porn and i was just
so trying to be the cool girl that i was
like it's okay babe we'll just do
another time yeah looking back now i
wish i would have just had like a really
calm don't conversation don't you mean
don't be like you're addicted to porn i
would just like have a conversation and
maybe offer like can you record us
having sex and like by the way that's
like such a good idea
you're giving such good advice let's see
if you can go three for three okay
this one is probably more in my
wheelhouse though okay hi claudia and
jackie oh sorry hi claudia shannon
making the short and sweet but how do i
tell my fiance's brother's girlfriend a
dear friend of mine that she is
butchering her her already beautiful
perfect face with facetune every picture
she posts she edits the absolute [ __ ]
out of her face hair body etc and it's
getting out of control i mean everyone
uses a little face tune but she's going
over the top okay we just recently went
to my bachelorette party and she edited
every picture of us not me just her okay
she edits herself to the point where if
you saw her in a photo and in real life
you wouldn't think it was the same
person do i say anything or just let her
live she's much younger than me so i'd
like to give her some advice but i also
don't want to offend her since i really
do love our friendship and she's not
hurting anyone so is it even worth
saying anything just curious to hear
your thoughts sincerely a toaster that's
facetune subscription just expired all
right i'm very pro facetune um you will
pretty much like never see a photo of me
on the internet that was taken on an
iphone that hasn't been i love a tweet
nipped tucked the whole thing i love a
tweak
um professional photos like a getty
image i don't do because like that's
like embarrassing um
however i have honed this skill over the
years like you you might not know which
pictures
but there was a time like on my timehop
i will see a photo that was like there's
we've all been there there's literally
like a person behind me whose life got
cut off because it was in my way
so it's something you definitely learn
over time and i imagine if somebody had
told me back then like claudia you
literally like it's so obvious i would
have been grateful for the tip but it's
all about delivery it's all about the
delivery and i um we had a friend in my
friend group who was doing it a lot and
we did end up telling her this is your
here's the thing here's why it's
embarrassing that your um
fiance's brother's girlfriend girlfriend
is doing it um it's embarrassing because
everyone knows what it looks like we are
all evolved enough now that you can spot
a face tuner in two seconds back then
when we were like boxing nobody knew
maybe not everyone realized it like now
it's so obvious that it's almost like
criminal if you don't tell her and help
her out so that's true delivery is
everything um i sometimes take the
approach of like making it a joke like
haha like a girl like make it like
almost kind of like funny in a joke but
like everyone knows behind every joke
there's some seriousness behind it right
and she's younger than you so she's like
already like probably impressionable
like you need to be really soft soft but
i just i do think you should say
something and you were already so nice
in your delivery with the question you
were like she's gorgeous you seem like a
nice girl i think you should pull up a
photo that you have of her that has not
been edited and say like i was just
looking at this photo i was thinking how
gorgeous you looked like you're so
pretty i know sometimes like you like
tweak your photos with it and be like
that's fine i do it too like sometimes
you know pimples or yeah and say yeah i
do it too because like i think we all
like every course there's gonna be
someone listening and i don't touch any
of my [ __ ] well like i do yeah i do no
shame i just make myself look like i
looked when i walked out the door by the
end of the night when you're taking
photos sometimes you don't look like
when you walked out the door so you know
i'm when i'm editing like i make myself
look how i looked when i walked out the
door five years ago 20 pounds ago
like just know like you've never seen a
picture of me not edited but but i also
do this podcast and i can't edit the
podcast so if you really want to know
what i look like yeah i'm like whatever
it's right [ __ ] but i don't care like
that's how i live with with peace in my
heart so if that bothers you feel free
to unfollow me but like i'm protecting
my heart yeah and you're allowed to do
that and i think she is allowed to do
that too but if it's like if it's
embarrassing no of course like you want
to protect her she she is going to
regret it in five years when she's uh
you know what that's also just a part of
growing up sometimes people need to make
their own mistakes and learn the hard
way and and she will learn the hard way
by having her uh boyfriend's fiance's
fee brothers feel girlfriend i cannot
you could tell she was a little
embarrassed but like she literally
stopped and then and then from this
point forward she would send us photos
and be like and ask for help is this too
much and we'd be like um no you tweet
that one get it or someone would be like
your arm's [ __ ] in that one yeah yeah
yeah she would have that's helpful you
have like a sounding board i do that
with my sisters i'm like this is this
two i say is this two-tuned i send that
all the time i say did i edit this too
much and they're like no it's good yeah
or my eye it's too bright when you're
looking at a photo for so long adding
filters face tuning you become
blind to it you yeah
exactly and sometimes it takes a fresh
set of eyes yeah
so just this is totally a fine thing to
say
come at it from like a really kind of
maternal nice way you already sound like
you are though yeah i'm not worried
you're gonna crush it um and that was
your toasters if you guys want to write
in for next wednesday it's dear toasters
gmail.com shannon's new podcast is
available anywhere you can get your
podcast it's called probably a podcast
it is on toast news network if you wanna
just go click the link in our bio or
click the link in shannon's bio um new
episodes are dropping every tuesday you
can also watch them you can a lot of our
tnn shows don't have videos but you do
it's super premium we have an episode
together if you guys we do never saw it
check it out you also have great
interviews with like hannah burner all
the girlies yeah all the girlies um it's
really good i'm obviously it's [ __ ]
great and you're probably shannon ford
on instagram instagram tick tock all the
thank you so much for doing this last
minute yay and i'm so excited for our
lunch
yes
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning tell us the money morning
show where we deliver the past live
stories that you need to know everybody
through friday on youtube watching this
on youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available podcasts and we're
podcasting found so spotify just you're
probably ridiculous possible please wait
for those packets mine is more until you
find everybody better beautiful sunnies
hope you guys have an amazing hump day
there is no show tomorrow um i am taking
a personal day so and jackie's still
sick so there's no show tomorrow but
hopefully jackie will be back on friday
if not i'll make ben come or margo
there'll be a show friday not tomorrow
thank you love you bye